- Hello, I'm Louie King.
- King of Broadway.
- Action.
- The story of "Little Voice" is about
a young woman named Bess King,
and she's stepping into
young adulthood.
Her brother has moved
into a group home.
- Louie is Bess' older brother.
- Everything you need
to know about Broadway.
- He's all into showbiz.
- Kevin is uniquely abled.
We went on a nation-wide
search for Kevin.
There is something unforgettable,
something so precious about him.
He's just a really special actor.
- I believe that my career
as an autistic person
can show what everybody can do.
Working in theatre requires
a certain theatrical flare.
Oh, my God!
It's Nicholas Christopher!
Will you sign my playbill?
- Kevin embraced learning about
theatre in New York.
It was great to watch him
dig into all of that.
- Whoo!
- To find someone who could not
just fit the character as written,
but elevate it.
And we finally found Kevin.
- These were our favorite days
on set were being
any of the scenes where we were
working with Louie or his buddies.
Had an incredible
experience with Kevin.
- Kevin is an incredibly
committed actor.
- This is big news.
- Every scene we ever did
was so much fun.
- Here are your tickets.
Enjoy the show.
One unexpected moment
can change your whole future.
♪ I'm coming back to you ♪